a t to close Downtown San Francisco
flagship store
I can only wonder why I didn't read the
story yet we just pulled up they say
consumer shopping habits continue to
change and we're changing with them that
means serving customers where they are
through the right mix of retail stores
digital channels and our phone-based
care team he said there's still two ATT
locations within one mile of their
financial district store the closure
isn't unique to SF the Union Square
store will shutter August 1st a similar
store in Chicago on Michigan Avenue will
close on the same day leaving the
nation's only ATT flagship store in
Dallas interesting I wonder why Dallas I
wonder what Texas might be doing to
where they're okay keeping their store
open but Chicago and SF I think that
somebody was just walking into the at T
store one day and they're just like
that's just one crack needle too many on
their foot they're just like sorry
that's enough heroin in my feet for one
day yeah you know when they have to put
all their phones behind vaults yeah if
they didn't Walmart just say that in San
Francisco also that they're they're
eventually I think they're going to shut
down but now they have everything
there's no Walmart is closing uh stores
across the country because of crime yeah
I mean Walgreens everywhere and for a
lot of people Walmart is a uh is their
main grocery store it's their main
access to food and so this is a big
problem there's a I think a Walgreens I
think it's in Chicago where you walk in
there's no products there's a wall with
a with an iPad and you walk up and type
it that's what I was talking about
Chicago I thought it was San Francisco
and then they they bring the items out
to you after you pay wow man it's really
funny because I remember when Amazon
wanted to launch that store where you
didn't there's no cashiers you walk in
grab whatever you want walk out it
automatically charges you yeah I I
reached out to uh to Amazon After
figuring out a very simple way of
bypassing the system
and they said effectively what I was
told was that uh shrinkage doesn't
matter that much because they saved so
much money on overhead by not having the
staff to do to check out that they can
absorb those costs expected
but it is fascinating that they thought
they could do something like that I
really don't think that'll work out in
the long run because if people aren't
scared to steal and walk past security
what do you think is going to happen
when they walk in the building and
there's no nothing there's nobody yeah
they're gonna walk and take whatever
they want walk out what are you gonna do
about it you think a cop's gonna go find
a guy because he took ten dollars of the
food ain't gonna happen especially not
in San Francisco if they have any there
I mean they're not even allowed to
engage the police even if they do well
there's the uh the thousand dollar limit
in SF so if Amazon really tries to do
these futuristic cashier list stores
people are going to walk in and be like
it's not even illegal to take whatever
you want I mean it's if if you're
incentivizing people to steal I've sadly
learned this in life is that human
nature does not always lean toward the
best behavior it tends to inherently
head toward the worst and and you have
to deter people on some level uh and so
it's you know I have friends who work in
department stores and they're like we're
not even allowed to even say anything do
you have a physical store for their
watches nope no retailers I I don't want
an egg I you know it would be cool to
have a like eggard physical store that
would just have a showcase and uh I
would like it just for the kind of
legacy of the company maybe in Florida
in Florida where I live now I ran away
from California as well I was going to
say because it's probably the only safe
place you know yeah you can set up in
West Virginia you'd be pretty good there
but in terms of higher density foot
traffic in a big Urban store Florida's
probably your best bet I think so too I
think Florida's a I mean I have I have a
buddy who opened a sunglass store over
there and he's you know he's doing
really well Florida's just become such a
crazy Hub of over the past two years
three years it's just exploded yeah
um so especially South Florida where I
am it's it's just the amount of change
so quickly scares me on some level
because I'm like this cannot be
sustainable but so long as people are
flooding out of those States you talk
about they're going to keep flooding
into other states in Florida Texas those
are really desirable well come on let's
think about it you have choices here you
can live in San Francisco where you're
going to step in human poop or you can
live in Florida where there are
beautiful men on the beach Ceviche nice
man comes and brings you pina colada
you're sitting back you put your feet up
no drag shows for kids none of that I
don't know you choose is there any worry
that like there's a constant worry right
that when people flock out of these
cities that they're they don't really
think it through entirely and then they
end up bringing their voting habits to
these other states and then you have to
worry about those States eventually
slowly transforming over time because
they don't connect in their brain that
the things they were voting for were
what yeah I was gonna say they never
promised to leave their voting habits no
they don't I think I think DeSantis has
proven that to not be uh something we
should fear because he got a million new
votes because he's the exception though
because of the Cuban vote and the fear
of socialism you do not necessarily have
that from a left-leaning liberal who
leaves California but Texas also did see
a redshift yeah and and didn't they also
heavily restrict mail-in ballots in both
those States they may have yeah that
could also be a big factor
um I think two things I think we talked
about this before when uh Elon and Rogan
leave California for Texas it's not that
they are bringing their policies it's
they bring staff the employees work for
their companies are not conservatives
and if they have to relocate for work or
say hey it's an opportunity then you're
bringing liberal voters that is scary to
me yep if Florida goes down
I gotta run away again the last question
well there's always West Virginia all
right but we we've we've got our stuff
happening in West Virginia too yeah
oh I don't know if I should talk about
it just yet maybe we should wait yeah
probably yeah but man now I feel so
there's just there's just woke stuff
happening in West Virginia oh really and
you know the it's it's the second most
Trump supporting state in the country
it's like 86 support for Trump most
people here are every county in the
state went for Trump right and they're
and they're even even where it's like
potentially mixed it leans still for
Trump it's close but uh most people here
who aren't even staunch conservative are
just in agreement with us on most of
these issues and you're seeing this
stuff emerge and I think it's because
the average person doesn't care and I
think it's because conservatives don't
engage in community activism so the the
fundamental problem I see for
conservatives in general there's there's
like a multi-faceted kind of problem
here that I see happening I think one of
the first things that you you see that's
really bad for conservatives is that
they rely so much on individuality as
opposed to uh kind of like a hive
mentality that you see on the left it's
just far more effective because once you
have a sense of kind of that Hive
mentality it's this that warm and fuzzy
feeling I was telling you about in
Hollywood it's a really good feeling
when you show up on set and it's warm
and everyone's friends with you and you
feel important the left is very good at
creating that sentiment across the the
board on everything they do with
messaging with community and the right
lacks in that department they're not
emotionally driven in their advertising
and their messaging and their movies
like because they feel it in the family
they they keep that aspects for the
family for the family side of things
whereas the other side looks to find it
in their profession it's an advantage
though it is they also they also
Coalition build better and they they go
door to door like I've never had a
right-wing political candidate ever come
door to door to me with you know with
you know people reaching out to say Hey
how do you feel about this person do you
want to vote for this person but I've
certainly had a lot of people uh come to
my door like there's people like when it
was like Craig Ellis and in Minnesota
was like they're like oh he's here for
attorney general I'm like isn't that the
guy who beat his wife and they're like I
don't know about that I'd have to check
on that like you know but they're they
like in that time period before that
election I had three four candidates all
Democrats had people coming door to door
to talk to you about it and I just us
don't see that do you think part of that
is because you were in a liberal City
and so Republicans saw it as lost ground
already I didn't see the point in
battling it out I don't know how it how
the voting goes because like where I
lived out there was fairly unique I was
uh in either direction I was a mile from
what would have been an urban center
meaning that that would have gone
heavily blue but then to the you know a
mile the other way and I'm in a fairly
nice and a very nice suburb but it
doesn't really matter for the voting
yeah so I don't know where you know but
you didn't vote in the suburb you voted
in the city center like that's what you
were voting for so yeah they probably
saw it as a lost cause well these
weren't no these were state level
elections these weren't even County or
anything like this so these would have
been people like he this is attorney
general for the state right so that's
they could have gone through the whole
area it wouldn't have mattered so I
don't think it would have been seen as
ground loss I just know that in my I get
more text messages you know the you get
random text messages it's never even
under my name it's for some person it's
like I've been getting text message for
a guy named Masood for like a decade and
I just never unsubscribed to it because
I just expected I like invited my suit
out for dinner I look forward well no
they think I'm missing have you thought
about voting for this person I'm like
I'm still in the suit it's kind of nice
but you know on those on those lonely
nights you're sitting there and you're
really going around it's dark and then
your phone vibrates and you smile yeah
it feels good to be exactly
no I think that uh Republicans famously
are terrible at their ground game right
like that's that's not anything new what
bothers me more is that they it's their
off season right like we get it you're
terrible I can say it 100 times get
better at going to the door find some
more Innovative voter registration
strategy what bothers me more is in the
off Seasons right now it's pride month
we're all these Pride parades we're
seeing all these things these are
moments where you're getting people who
are like-minded together in a
non-election year there are not
equivalents for conservatives right like
where are the I mean some states have
them but like more county fairs I would
like lots of Fourth of July like blocks
I want more things that non-political
slash leaning conservative people can go
to and connect with other people and
talk about hey what's going on in our
community or our state or our nation
right I feel like that's what we are
missing the off off your community
events and and the fun behind it yeah
like they're missing there's a
disconnect somewhere in conservative
messaging and events and I don't like
maybe it's because I'm like a hyper
artistic person I'm kind of like in that
sense I'm very liberal-minded and
there's a disconnect for me and I can't
put my finger on it with a lot of the
stuff that is for the right where I
don't even want to attend the event I
don't even I don't know what it is I
can't nail it down I think it's
something I I don't know how much anyone
follows this but like the New York and
Republicans have really exploded as a
club in the past couple years and it's
because because they made it fun they do
fun events they do they have interesting
speakers it's it's a community group and
I think this is something that we are
missing I think it's easy for a lot of
uh left leading people to get together
when they feel outraged and they're
going against the machine even though we
know they kind of are on the machine at
this point uh and conservatives don't
have those Community moments my favorite
thing that Trump has said is that we
need to have like a year-long
celebration for the 250th anniversary of
America right like less let's do this
like that sounds fun even if you're not
super into politics it's just fun to
have fun things to do you know what I
think it is with the art I think when
when it comes for the art like you said
you're liberal minded when it comes to
our you know Artistic Endeavors it's
because when the right creates art a lot
of the times it reeks of a sense of
desperation to win back something yes
that I do like I I I don't maybe I'm
upsetting some people but I heard the
the 81 million Vote song and I just I'm
like
just like that this isn't this isn't
working like it like there is whether
you like their messaging or not there is
more natural artistic Drive uh on the
left side of things and now it's shoved
into the entertainment full force now
but it wasn't always like that right so
yeah they could Coalition uh you know
better you know build better and I do
like the idea of more you know more
things that celebrate the country right
more fun but isn't it sad that anything
that celebrates the country is now
inherently a political issue rather than
a bipartisan one well that's nuts in
itself thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time